in this lecture we consider the single
most important life in this entire
course the life of Napoleon Bonaparte
Napoleon's conquests and his
administrative genius turned the French
Revolution from chaos and disorder to
stability and permanence in this lecture
which is number 18 we actually reach
halfway in our journey from the old
regime to modernity and Napoleon really
is the transitional figure now in a time
of revolution there is always the
problem of the army either the anti
Revolutionary Armed Forces or the new
Revolutionary Army what revolutions do
is to create a situation of potential or
actual anarchy and the power of an armed
force is the best antidote to anarchy
an army is a kind of social order on
June 4th 1790 Jean Frederick Count de
lattre dupa Minister of War and the new
French constitutional government warned
the National Assembly of the danger and
I quote His Majesty has this day sent me
to apprise you of the multiplied
disorders of which every day he receives
the most distressing intelligence the
army Lacock militare threatens to fall
into the most turbulent anarchy I see in
more than one Corps the bonds of
discipline relaxed or broken the most
unheard-of pretensions avowed directly
without any disguise the ordinance is
without force the Chiefs
without authority the military chest and
the colors carried off the authority of
the king himself proudly defied the
officers despised degraded threatened
driven away and some of them prisoners
in the midst of their Corps dragging on
a precarious life from the bosom of
disgust and humiliation to fill up the
measure of these horrors the common
dance of places have had their throats
cut under the eyes and almost in the
arms other on soldiers of their own
soldiers unquote now the principle of
equality which we discussed in the last
lecture was undermining the authority of
officers because the European Army was a
class matter
the officers were indeed they had to be
Nobles and the soldiers were mostly
peasants or Kay
the workers as we saw in lecture 17
equality as a doctrine is social
dynamite if all are equal why have
officers at all or if you have to have
them why not elect them now de la tour
du path warned that such an army was a
threat to the revolution itself and I
quote these evils are great but they are
not the worst consequences which may be
produced by such military insurrections
sooner or later they may Menace the
nation itself the nature of things
requires that the army should never act
but as an instrument the moment that
erecting itself into a deliberative body
it shall act according to its own
resolutions the government be it what it
may will immediately degenerate into a
military democracy a species a political
monster which has always ended by
devouring those who have produced it
unquote it was necessary therefore for
the revolution to find its own some new
form of discipline and of course its own
Armed Forces now the pole Ian's career
was entirely dependent on the situation
which de litter of du pan described and
he admitted it I am he said a child of
the revolution his career was not unique
he was and what I want to do first is
just to set out the structural
conditions constraints under which
Napoleon rose to power now the
revolution changed the career prospects
for everybody an open society meant
careers literally opened to the talents
as it was called and this was another
consequence of the principle of equality
they were no longer any gills to prevent
you from practicing a trade no class or
religious restrictions you could be
anything that you wanted to be there was
no chance for a Napoleon to rise under
the old regime although he had enough
noble ancestry to get into the cadet
Academy he had neither money nor
connections at court hence the great
generals of the Napoleonic Wars came
from varied social backgrounds but all
were of course very young and here are
the ages
Napoleon and his marshals in 1799
Napoleon was 30 Messina was 41 ney was
30 Nora was 32 Bernadotte 36 Davo 29
Juno 28 LUN 30 and so on
now brief biography of Napoleon
Bonaparte's necessary at this point to
illustrate what I'm talking about he was
born on August 15th 1769 in iho Corsica
shortly after the island had been
succeeded by us had been ceded by the
Genoese republic to france he was the
fourth child of carlo bonaparte a was a
lawyer and his wife Leticia Romilly know
his father belonged to an ancient Tuscan
noble family which had emigrated to
Corsica in the 16th century and that was
a stroke of luck because that four
quarters of nobility which the born
apart a family had was enough to let
Napoleon get into a Military Academy he
would have had no military career at all
if his father had not had that
background so he was able to enter a
Military Academy and he was commissioned
an officer in the artillery at the age
of 16 in 1787 he read a lot of
Enlightenment literature which was
exactly what Rob Speer was doing at the
same time although not common among army
officers then or for that matter now but
he would like Rob Speer have died an
obscurity
had it not been for the revolution for
comparison of the 26 marshals of the
Empire 16 started as troopers or
privates Victor was a drummer boy
Messina a smuggler and Azrael a Parisian
slum child none of these people would
have made it so the army was not in the
poliana creation the origin of the new
French tactics arose from the character
of the new French society and the new
French army had many similarities to the
American Continental Army of 1776 to
1783 it was an ad-hoc unplanned creation
why well because there were large scale
defections of former Royal officers who
were Nobles
and the terror eliminated many who had
the wrong background de la tour du pan
was himself guillotined by the terror in
1794 not because he was disloyal but
because he was account the effect of the
defections and the executions was to
produce a disintegration of the military
structures in the lack of discipline and
traditional training so there were
several unusual features of the french
army by 1793 one it had no proper
training anymore
two it had no decent supply system and
three it had by compensation the ability
to mobilize very very large numbers of
people the french revolutions greatest
military innovation was the draft the
introduction of universal conscription
the so called levy a mass meant total
mobilization of a whole society for the
first time in human history the decree
of August 23rd 1793 declared and I quote
from this moment until such time as our
enemies have been expelled from the
territories of the Republic all
Frenchmen are in a permanent state of
requisition for service in the armies
the young will go to fight married men
will forge weapons and transport
foodstuffs women will make tents and
clothes and serve in the hospitals while
children will shred old linen and old
men will be taken to the public squares
to rouse the courage of the young
soldiers and to preach hatred of Kings
and knee and the need for Republican
unity this was a unique explosion of
national power it was a stark contrast
with the professional army of the old
regime which used impressment beating
and drill half the army of Frederick the
great it was said was there to prevent
the other half from deserting and that
was one of the reasons why the
eighteenth-century army used these very
tight drill mechanisms very tight lines
and columns because as soon as the
soldiers were out of sight they had been
taken up as slaves anyway they'd escaped
so you had to keep an eye on them at all
times during the battle so the French
Revolution actually did create what the
Count de la tour du PAC called a
military democracy an army of zealots
and believers and with these army of new
beliefs
Seavers new tactics were possible
because the soldiers were free and
citizens who believed that what they
were doing was right and I want to give
you some examples of this
the French ended the practice of files
of troops standing up and firing in a
line Colonel Graham of the 90th British
foot was an observer with the Austrians
on the Audigy in 1796 and here's his
account of what he saw some French
sharpshooters concealed by bushes at the
edge of the river kept up a constant and
annoying fire on the fine regiment of
kale three battalions which were very
absurdly drawn up on the top of the dike
forming the great road on the left bank
of the river occasionally making
discharges to drive away their invisible
enemies by stepping back six or eight
yards and lying down on the reverse bank
of the dike not a shot from the enemy
would have told where as a loss of one
hundred and fifty men killed or wounded
was the consequence of this stupid
bravado as if the honor of such a
regiment under such circumstances could
be affected by the men being placed in a
position of security
unquote now honor is a category which
was an attribute of a gentleman the new
French soldiers were not gentlemen
anymore
hence the Revolution changed Society and
a changed Society of citizen soldiers
created a new type of army able to use
new tactics that's exactly what happened
during the American Revolutionary Wars
much to the horror of the British
Hessian Hanoverian officers who saw
these people creeping around in the
woods and lying down behind logs and
trees very ungentlemanly behavior but
then the Americans weren't gentlemen's
gentlemen either the Prussian military
reformer Gerhardt from scharnhorst noted
the new attitudes of the French soldiers
and I quote the physical agility and
high intelligence of the common man
enables the French to hire or marksman
to profit from all the advantages
offered by the terrain and general
situation while the phlegmatic Germans
Bohemians and Dutch form an open ground
and do nothing but what their officers
order them to do
so a revolution won its most important
battles from 1792 to 1795 Ellucian was
safe by the time that Napoleon seized
power
Napoleon was perhaps its most brilliant
general in the Year 1795 to 1799 but he
was not alone nor unique in that
capacity what was unique about Napoleon
was his personality and he was a genius
in the literal sense of the word
his powers rested on his personality
he's so-called charisma now the concept
of charisma as a political category was
invented in the 20th century but the
word is old it comes from a Greek word
meaning favor or gift and there are two
main meanings for it an extraordinary
power as of healing given by the
Christian Holy Spirit for the good of
the church or the modern meaning a
personal magic of leadership among
rousing special popular loyalty a kind
of magnetic charm or appeal now the
modern theory of charismatic leadership
was developed by the famous German
sociologist Max Weber who is an
enthusiast economist and political
scientist and Weber was interested in
the basic question why do people obey
and he developed three ideal types as he
called him to answer this question why
we obey and he called them his three
types of authority the first was
traditional which was the authority of a
tribal chief or a king or a priest we
obey because it's always been that way
a second is rational legal which is the
authority of the modern law bound state
we obey because it's the law when we get
a letter from the IRS we do what they
tell us because otherwise there will be
penalties but the third is charismatic
and that's the peculiar attraction of a
leader we obey because we believe in the
person who leads us now this kind of
leadership and we've seen quite a lot of
in the last hundred years
Hitler had it Mussolini had it and no
doubt in various ways Osama bin Laden
has it Napoleon was undoubtedly a
charismatic leader and here is some
evidence
of his impact on people one civil
servant called it the miracle of the
presence like Hitler or like Osama bin
Laden Napoleon had a strong sense of his
special mission in life after his great
victory in Italy in 1796 he wrote I
quote I realized I was a superior being
and conceived the ambition of performing
great things which had hitherto filled
my thoughts only as a fantastic dream I
saw the world flee beneath me as if I
were transported in air unquote other
people came to believe in his mission
because of his impact on them the
Prussian general HDL for New York a very
hard minded man described Napoleon as
follows quote owing to his thinness his
features were almost ugly in their
sharpness his walk was unsteady his
clothes neglected his appearance on the
whole produced an unfavorable impression
was in no way imposing but in spite of
his apparent bodily weakness he was
tough and sinewy and from under his deep
Far head there flashed despite his
sallow face the eyes of genius deep
seated large and of a greyish blue color
and before their glance and the words of
authority that issued from his thin pale
lips all bowed or general Dominique Van
Damme observed so it is that I who fear
neither God no the devil I'm ready to
tremble like a child when I approach him
Napoleon's care for his troops was
extraordinary
Tolstoy describes this in war and peace
which we should look at in lecture 34
but here's an example after his great
victory over the Austrians at varam in
1809 the Duke of Rovi goat recalled on
the following day the 7th of July
the Emperor wrote over the field of
battle according to his usual practice
to see if the hospital department had
caused all the wood to be removed as
this was harvest time the corn was very
high and it was impossible to see the
soldiers lying stretched upon the ground
many of those unfortunate wounded had
placed their handkerchiefs at the end of
their muskets and held them up as a
signal for assistance the emperor
repaired in person to every
part where he perceived such signals he
addressed words of consolation to the
wounded and would not move forward until
the last of them been carried off the
field he kept no one to attend him and
ordered marshal de Hawk to have all the
men picked up and to see that the
movable hospitals did not slacken their
exertions general de Rock was known for
his precision and severity the Emperor
therefore often selected him for
commissions of that nature his soldiers
responded to that kind of care with
complete and permanent loyalty to him as
a commander Napoleon had astonishing
physical and mental abilities he had the
capacity to work 18 to 20 hours a day
and he once went three days without
sleep but he was able to sleep at will I
quote different subjects and different
Affairs are arranged in my head as in a
cupboard when I wished to interrupt one
train of thought I shut the drawer and
open another do I wish to sleep I simply
closed all the doors drawers and am
asleep would do we could all do that
like Stalin he had total recall memory
which was extremely useful in commanding
armies of two hundred thousand men
without a radio or a telegraph or a
telephone Napoleon always had the
complete order of battle in his head and
knew where every platoon should have
been he could recall the names of
ordinary soldiers years after the battle
to those close to him it seemed that his
powers were almost godlike jean-baptiste
Bernadotte
was a French general who rose with
Napoleon and through his reputation made
Napoleon's Wars became implausibly King
of Sweden
Venna dynasty is still on the throne
Sweden in 1821 on hearing of the death
of Napoleon he delivered a speech in his
memory and I quote Napoleon has not been
conquered by men he was greater than any
of us God punished him because he relied
solely on his own intelligence until
that incredible instrument was so
strained that it broke unquote
Napoleon's rise to power followed the
arc of revolutionary developments he
supported the radicals RUP spear in the
Jacobins in 1793 in 94
and he's Jack amid sentiments gained in
the patronage Rupp's Pierre
hence like all Jacobins he was in
serious trouble
when Rob's beer fell he was either lucky
or shrewd because he waited for his
chance in Paris and didn't leave when a
right-wing rising tried to seize power
in 1795 Napoleon was appointed to defend
the convention and shot down the columns
of rebels marching against it on October
5th 1795 and thus saved the National
Convention and the Republic this quote
whiff of grapeshot as he called it made
him famous and he married joséphine de
Beauharnais which was a very good match
as she was older and much better
connected she rose with him until he
needed a better wife as we shall see in
1809 and married a Habsburg princess and
divorced Josephine the real genius of
Napoleon was revealed first in his
brilliant campaign in Italy 1796 97 and
which he constantly dissipated orders
from Paris and did what he liked and
succeeded he was then given command of
the army of Egypt in order to destroy
the British Empire and like Rommel in
1941 1942 Napoleon had dramatic
successes at first and got as far as
Syria which Rommel never did on August
the 1st 1798 however Admiral Horatio
Nelson British Admiral destroyed the
French fleet and the Allies began to
push the French revolutionary armies
back in Europe it's an exact parallel
what happened which was what happened to
the war in the Mediterranean in the
second world war on October an August
22nd 1799 Napoleon left his command in
Egypt which was after all an active
desertion punishable by death and
there's a wonderful scene about his
arrival in which the then director Kuno
says so Citizen Bonaparte you seemed not
to be in your command but they were
scared to him they didn't do anything
and he made contact with two members of
the government who were plotting to
overthrow the existing system CA and
Rajai du Clos now the brains behind the
plot was the abbe Emmanuel say a says a
true survivor and key player in the
revolution says was a priest a bourgeois
origin
who became instantly famous in 1789
because he wrote a pamphlet called what
is the Third Estate now if I can draw
your memory back to lecture 14 the old
estates-general of 1614 was called in
1789 because absolutism was dead they
needed a new parliament but nobody knew
how it worked it was composed of a first
estate of clergy a second estate of
nobility and a kind of general Third
Estate so see as is pamphlet what was
what is the third the third estate was
very timely and see as his answer was
even more timely the third estate he
said is the nation now see as have been
active at every stage between 1789 and
1799 when he was asked what did you do
unto the Jacobins Cs replied I survived
and she has had been looking for some
time to put an end to the chaos that was
obtaining under the directory as he said
I need a saber somebody I could use and
he found Napoleon the coup d'etat took
place on November the 9th 1799 with the
help of Tallyho another survivor and
Fouchet the secret police chief ca's
designed a new dictatorial Constitution
based on the Roman Republic with
Napoleon ca's and Pierre what we do
close consuls Napoleon simply deposed
them in due course and took power the
insiders had got it wrong and I'd like
if I had more time I develop this but I
think insiders always get it wrong as
they did with Hitler or with Mussolini
because they know the rules of the
existing game they don't realize that
they're dealing with a charismatic
leader who's going to change them all so
they underestimate him and we'll see
this again when we come to Napoleon the
third in lecture 25 now Napoleon
transformed France as much as the
Revolution had done France today is as
much Napoleon's work as it was that of
the men of 1789 or 1793 he said about to
tame the French Revolution Napoleonic
Authority rested on first the loyalty to
the army which he always had his
personal charisma which none could take
away from him and see his use of the
plebiscite which he described as
authority from
above confidence from below the results
of the first on his assumption of power
show that these tactics really work yes
votes three million eleven thousand and
seven no votes 1562 but unlike some of
the more recent parasites this was a
real one now dictators like plebiscites
the electoral college in the
constitution of 1787 in the United
States was designed precisely to prevent
dictators using direct election or
plebiscites the second thing that the
polling did was he preserved the
material gains of the Revolution
Napoleon was not an ordinary military
dictator he was still in many ways the
Jacobin in a reformer but he knew how to
choose the right bits the French
Revolution was as Albert mattias once
said history's greatest land transfer
people had seized land the peasants had
seized land and in the new dictatorial
constitution of the year eight of
December 25th 1799 he confirmed the sale
of national property and upheld
legislation against the Emma grace in
other words if you had got it you could
keep it on the other hand the new
Constitution no longer guaranteed the
rights of man it made no mention of
liberty equality and fraternity which
meant that it was renouncing Jacobin
radicalism so the ideas are down but the
property is up so the new dictatorship
secured the ill-gotten gains of the
winners but cut out the radical ideology
he was too shrewd to try to suppress the
principle of equality the Uniform Code
of Justice established equality before
the law and together with these other
codes is still the permanent law of
Europe today and of the state of
Louisiana in the United States
Napoleon transformed the administration
of France by creating a new Ministry of
Interior with new powers
he created a prefectural system to
govern the eighty three departments of
France and closed the local democratic
assemblies the prefectural system is
still the way in which France is
administered his dictatorship aimed to
enforce unity uniformity and control
France was modernized by the
creation of other fundamental
institutions the Council of State the so
called great schools in which the civil
service are trained and so on but there
was for Napoleon always a problem of
legitimacy after all Napoleon had taken
power by force and fraud and during his
entire career he pursued an elusive goal
how to establish the regime for good one
answer was repression he created the
first modern police state and introduced
very severe press censorship a second
answer was to bribe people he created a
whole range of new rewards for example
the Legion of Honor was established on
May 19th 1802 one of his advisors a
former Jacobin asked but it's a bauble
sire
- which napoleon replied men are ruled
by almost nothing else another device
was to win this - to win the support was
the establishment of the empire in 1800
and to a plebiscite was held shall
napoleon bonaparte be consul for life in
august an overwhelming vote granted him
the prolongation of his consulate as
well as the right to designate his
successor france was practically a
monarchy already Heatran transformed the
consulate into an empire on December 2nd
1804 the Pope performed the coronation
but Napoleon took the crown himself and
placed it on his head a deeply symbolic
act he made the entire Corsican family
into princes Joseph his oldest brother
became King of Naples and so on and all
the many brothers and sisters suddenly
found themselves kings and queens in
ways that they would never have imagined
a new aristocracy was created for the
new men and women and all his generals
became kings princes and dukes he
restored religion the French Revolutions
attack on the Catholic Church which we
saw in lecture 16 he reversed and in
July of 1847
now the Poland's attitude to religion
was extremely cynical and manipulative
and I quote there's only one way to
encourage morality and that's to
establish religion
xiety cannot exist without some being
richer than others and this inequality
cannot exist without religion when one
man is dying of hunger next door to one
is who is stuffing himself with food the
poor man
simply cannot accept the disparity
unless some Authority tells him God
wishes it so in heaven things will be
different
thereafter so now he's an emperor and
he's made peace with the Catholic Church
but he still needs further support for
the regime and so in due course he
decide to marry into the ruling family
of Europe the hapsburgs
and he marries the Habsburg princess
there's a rich rich irony in all this
the French revolutionaries guillotined
the Queen marie-antoinette and Napoleon
married Marie Louise the eldest daughter
of Francis the second and niece of Marie
Antoinette in other words he married the
niece of the guillotine Queen nothing
could be more except symbolic and she
was married to Napoleon in Paris in 1800
and 1810 the following year she bore him
the long-desired
heir the king of Rome and the future
Duke of rice Tut but even this didn't
actually work Napoleon's rule was and
remained a military dictatorship
it was his defeats in war which
eventually destroyed the Empire now in
this lecture we haven't got time to look
at it but we will in the next lecture on
magic be looking at the ways in which
the character of the Napoleonic Empire
actually undermined Napoleon's rule he
exploited the conquered territories
which was in contrast with the
revolutionary ideals which the French
Revolution had embodied the old regime
states gradually learned the lessons
they reformed their societies they
transformed their armies they began to
imitate the French revolutionary spirit
the role of Great Britain was crucial
like Hitler Napoleon could not conquer
Britain because see power is invisible
and was not available to his
revolutionary army and the role of
Russia was the other parallel
between Napoleon and Hitler because here
too
Napoleon was unable to control the East
but the comparison between the Nazi
Empire and Napoleon greatly favors
Napoleon Hitler left Europe a smoking
ruin with millions dead
Napoleon left Europe permanently
modernized and stabilised laws which
were rationalized under the Napoleonic
Code states with rational boundaries
people with new elites and careers open
to the talent and above all he left the
legend of his universal genius his wars
were great engines of modernization
they brought mobilization literacy and
popular involvement in Thomas nipa dies
great history of Germany in the 19th
century he begins with the following
simple sentence i'm unfun VAR Napoleon
in the beginning was Napoleon this
course is now at its halfway point
Napoleon is the greatest of all the
modernizing lives we study in this
course